- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je suis heureuse
de souhaiter la bienvenue
à trois de nos collègues.
Madame Eléonore Caroit...
Monsieur Meyer Habib...
Et monsieur Karim Ben Cheikh.
Ils ont été réélus députés les 15
et 16 avril derniers,
respectivement dans des
circonscriptions des Français
établis hors de France.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions gouvernement.
La première va être posée par
monsieur Antoine Léaument pour le
groupe La France Insoumise.
- Antoine Léaument: Madame la
Première ministre, 2,3 millions de
manifestants vous ont dit le 1er
mai leur opposition à la réforme
des retraites.
En vous acharnant, vous abîmez sa
démocratie, vous abîmez la
démocratie, en utilisant les
outils les plus autoritaires de la
Ve République.
Vous abîmez la démocratie, en
bafouant la Constitution, qui dit
que la République, c'est le
gouvernement du peuple par le
peuple et pour le peuple.
Vous abîmez la démocratie en
utilisant la police, non pour
garantir le droit à manifester,
mais pour le réprimer.
Votre bilan, c'est la violence!
Ca suffit!
Policiers brûlés!
Journalistes frappés!
Manifestants mutilés!
Les coupables, c'est vous!
Nous apportons notre soutien à
tous les blessés.
Vous vouliez tourner la page des
retraites?
C'est raté!
Vous ne savez plus où vous allez.
Où que ce soit, les casseroles
vous accompagnent.
Vous ne pouvez plus gouverner.
La crise est maintenant politique.
La Ve République permet d'agir
sans le peuple.
Et contre lui, elle n'est plus
légitime.
En bafouant ces principes
républicains, vous accélérez sa
chute, et la vôtre!
A bas Macron et la mauvaise
république!
Vive la constituante et la VIe
République!
Ici, c'est la France, celle d'un
peuple insoumis dont la nation
s'est fondée par une révolution!
On ne fait pas taire le peuple, on
l'écoute!
On ne le maîtrise pas, on le
respecte!
Nous ne céderons pas!
Vous vouliez en avoir fini le 14
juillet.
Vous aurez votre prise de la
Bastille!
Quand retirerez-vous votre réforme
des retraites?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, monsieur le
député Léaument, je ne suis sans
doute pas l'interlocuteur que vous
auriez désiré, mais je n'ai pas
tout compris de votre question,
sauf que vous n'étiez pas content
et que vous n'aimiez pas la
police.
Je regrette très sincèrement,
monsieur le député que, pour la
première question au gouvernement,
après des violences absolument
inacceptables, qui ont blessé 405
policiers et gendarmes, hier, dont
un policier qui aurait pu...
Chacun l'a vu à la télévision.
Il aurait pu mourir!
Il est brûlé au deuxième degré
quoi.
Que vous n'ayez pas un mot pour ce
père de famille démontre votre
humanisme.
Protestation et applaudissements
Monsieur le député Léaument, vous
nous avez habitué...
Ce n'est même pas votre haine
anti-police, mais vous n'avez même
pas un mot pour les trois
militants communistes qui ont été
agressés par les black blocs.
Si le Parti Communiste a fait, ce
matin, un communiqué extrêmement
clair, soutenant les forces de
l'ordre, protégeant le droit à
manifester et condamnant les
violences, vous êtes les
responsables de ces violences
quand vous ne condamnez pas les
gens qui, à coups de cocktails
Molotov, menacent notre
démocratie!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît...
La parole est à monsieur le
président Laurent Marcangeli pour
le groupe Horizons.
- Laurent Marcangeli: Mes chers
collègues, aujourd'hui, un jeune
homme de 27 ans est hospitalisé,
brûlé au deuxième degré.
Qu'a-t-il fait pour se retrouver
dans ce lit d'hôpital?
Son métier.
Vêtu de l'uniforme, il a participé
aux opérations de maintien de
l'ordre, de protection des
personnes et des biens lors de la
manifestation du 1er mai à Paris.
C'est là qu'il a été touché par un
cocktail Molotov, le blessant
grièvement.
Je veux ici, au nom du groupe
Horizons et apparentés, rendre
hommage à ce jeune homme, aux 405
policiers et gendarmes blessés ce
lundi, mais également aux 1083
membres des forces de sécurité
intérieure qui ont également été
victimes d'atteintes physiques
depuis le mois de janvier.
Applaudissements
...
Brouhaha
Protestations et applaudissements
Qu'il est triste de voir que
certains représentants de la
nation ne se lèvent pas pour
applaudir.
Ce drame, l'utilisation d'armes
artisanales de guerre mettant à
jour l'utilisation inacceptable
d'armes contre nos forces de
l'ordre, dédiées à la protection
de nos concitoyens.
Nous ne pouvons nous résoudre
d'accepter les scènes de violence
auxquelles nous assistons, qui, il
est clair, ne sont ni improvisées,
ni spontanées, mais bien préparées
et présidées par une logique du
désordre, du chaos, d'anarchie,
qui vise à remettre en cause et à
nier l'autorité de l'Etat.
C'est intolérable!
Madame la Première ministre, ma
question est la suivante.
Comment limiter les risques
auxquels sont exposés nos forces
de l'ordre dans le cadre des
manifestations actuelles?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le président Marcangeli,
hier, près de 800.000 Français ont
défilé à l'occasion du 1er mai.
La très grande majorité des
manifestations s'est parfaitement
déroulée.
Et je veux saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité des organisations
syndicales et l'engagement des
préfets et des forces de l'ordre
pour garantir la liberté
fondamentale de manifester et
préserver la sécurité des
cortèges.
Dans plusieurs grandes villes,
notamment Paris, Lyon ou Nantes,
comme cela avait déjà été le cas
lors de précédentes
manifestations, des groupes
violents se sont mêlés à des
cortèges pacifiques.
Ces groupes n'ont qu'un objectif:
s'en prendre aux forces de
l'ordre, créer le désordre et le
chaos.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
cette violence est intolérable et
nous devons tous, responsables
publics, la condamner avec la plus
grande fermeté.
Elle est intolérable, car elle
donne le droit à manifester et
éclipse les idées.
Elle est intolérable, car elle
crée des dommages importants dans
l'espace public.
Je pense aux commerçants, aux
artisans, aux particuliers, aux
maires qui, ce matin ont découvert
de lourds dégâts sur leurs
vitrines et leur mobilier urbain.
Ces violences sont intolérables,
enfin, car elles causent des
blessures.
Elles mettent en danger les
manifestants font malheureusement
des blessés.
Elles ont surtout pour cible les
forces de l'ordre.
Hier...
Protestations
Hier, plus de 400 policiers...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
Merci de l'écouter.
- Elisabeth Borne: Hier, près de
400 policiers et gendarmes ont été
blessés, dont certains grièvement.
Les images que nous avons vues,
notamment celle d'un policier
brûlé par un cocktail Molotov,
sont insupportables et elles
illustrent qu'un nouveau palier a
été franchi dans la violence.
Avec vous, je veux dire de nouveau
tout mon soutien et celui de mon
gouvernement à nos forces de
sécurité intérieure.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
dans notre pays, on peut
légitimement exprimer sa colère
sur la voie publique, mais on ne
peut pas s'en prendre à
l'intégrité physique des femmes et
des hommes qui, par leur uniforme,
incarnent la République et nous
protègent.
Je veux le redire ici: les auteurs
de ces exactions seront identifiés
et traduits en justice.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la
présidente Marine Le Pen.
Pour le groupe Rassemblement
National.
- Marine Le Pen: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Si l'attachement des Mahorais à la
France n'est plus à démontrer,
l'attachement des gouvernements
successifs à Mayotte manque
cruellement de preuves.
Quand les Comores voisines
refusent d'appliquer le droit
international en reprenant leurs
ressortissants, c'est évidemment
sur la voix ferme de la septième
puissance mondiale.
Quand les Mahorais constatent
quotidiennement qu'ils n'ont aucun
droit de plus que les étrangers,
souvent clandestins, ils
regrettent amèrement que les lois
de la République ne soient pas
plus favorables à ceux qui
possèdent la nationalité
française.
Quand les Mahorais entendent des
juges dire qu'il faut tout faire
pour lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine, ils prennent le chaos
économique qui en résulte comme
une fatalité.
Il n'y a pas de fatalité, mais
bien des choix politiques.
C'est ce que je dis aux Mahorais.
Nous n'avons pas à financer les
pays qui bafouent le droit
international et organisent la
submersion migratoire de la
France.
Nous n'avons pas à accueillir sur
notre sol les délinquants
étrangers qui bafouent les valeurs
d'asile et d'accueil.
Mais oui, nous avons à mettre un
terme au cauchemar que vivent des
Français, notamment en changeant
profondément une partie de notre
droit sur l'immigration.
J'ai, vous le savez, un texte prêt
à être mis à référendum.
Nos propositions sont toujours en
ligne.
Madame la Première ministre,
qu'allez-vous faire pour Mayotte?
Avez-vous compris qu'il faut
changer radicalement de vision et
mettre en place une politique
dissuasive d'immigration?
- Elisabeth Borne: Madame la
présidente Le Pen, votre question
a une vertu: de faire entendre de
nouveau votre voix dans cet
hémicycle après des semaines de
mutisme et de silence.
Malheureusement, c'est de nouveau
pour vous placer dans la posture,
dans les caricatures, au mépris de
la réalité.
Je pense que les Mahorais ont
compris que le gouvernement est à
leurs côtés.
Le gouvernement a mobilisé des
forces de l'ordre exceptionnelles
pour ramener la sécurité, pour
ramener la tranquillité à Mayotte.
Ce sont à la fois des policiers,
des gendarmes et des magistrats
qui sont sur place pour pouvoir,
dans un premier temps, arrêter les
principaux responsables de la
délinquance à Mayotte, et c'est ce
qui a été fait.
Les principales cibles qui avaient
été identifiées ont d'ores et déjà
été arrêtées.
Pour lutter contre l'habitat
insalubre et, malgré le jugement
que vous mentionnez, ces
destructions sont en cours avec
des relogements à la clé dans des
habitats de qualité.
Par ailleurs, nous luttons
évidemment aux côté des Mahorais
contre l'immigration clandestine,
qui est un de nos combats.
Vous pouvez avoir votre point de
vue, mais la manifestation qui
s'est tenue la semaine dernière,
avec plus de 1000 Mahorais en
soutien à l'action du
gouvernement, est la preuve que,
sur place, nous sommes aux côtés
des Mahorais et ils l'ont compris.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
La parole est à madame Emeline
K/Bidi pour le groupe GDR.
- Emeline K/Bidi: Avant toute
chose, au nom du groupe GDR, je
souhaite adresser toutes mes
félicitations au peuple
polynésien, au parti
indépendantiste et à nos camarades
pour leur brillante victoire aux
élections territoriales en
Polynésie française ce week-end.
Félicitations à eux.
Ma question s'adresse maintenant à
monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur.
Depuis quelques jours, l'opération
Wuambushu est un fiasco.
Il faut des solutions et des
moyens.
Pour endiguer la misère, le
mal-logement, le chômage, le
manque d'eau, des centaines de
policiers ne sauraient suffire.
La France, pays des droits de
l'homme, n'est pas à la hauteur,
ici.
Au lieu de mesures efficaces et
concrètes sur le long terme, vous
utilisez les violences et bafouez
les droits humains.
Quelle aberration!
Les expulsions sont jugées
irrégulières.
Les Comores refusent de récupérer
leurs ressortissants et les appels
à la haine et la violence se
multiplient.
Les Mahorais ont le droit de vivre
en sécurité.
Oui, ils ont le droit à des
conditions de vie décentes, mais
jamais, jamais, le groupe GDR ne
se résignera à l'usage de la force
et de la violence abusive contre
des femmes, des hommes et des
enfants dont le sol tort est de
n'être pas né sur la bonne île.
Je suis inquiète pour Mayotte et
la Réunion.
Quelles solutions avez-vous prévu
pour les mineurs isolés?
Quelle solution pour les
Mahoraises et les Mahorais qui
sont en droit d'espérer mieux de
notre pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
au ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, madame la
députée, je veux moi aussi, au nom
du gouvernement de la République,
féliciter la nouvelle liste élue
en Polynésie française.
Le gouvernement s'apprête à
travailler avec eux et à saluer
les Polynésiens qui ont voté
malgré des conditions climatiques
difficiles.
Je me tiens à la disposition du
gouvernement de Polynésie dès
qu'il sera formé.
Je me tiens, madame la députée, à
votre interrogation.
A Mayotte, l'immigration
incontrôlée, ce sont vos mots...
Il y a une difficulté qui tient à
la démographie.
80 % des enfants qui naissent dans
les maternités locales ne sont pas
des enfants Mahorais.
Ils viennent souvent des Comores,
mais aussi d'autres pays de
l'Afrique des Grands Lacs ou de
Madagascar.
C'est aussi le cas d'une
surpopulation puisqu'on est passé
à 200.000 habitants de plus à
Mayotte.
Cela pose des tas de problèmes,
d'eau, de sécurité, d'accès à
l'alimentation et à l'école où les
enfants travaillent souvent une
demi-journée sur 2.
Il faut maîtriser la démographie
et ça tient notamment pour la
maîtrise de nos frontières.
Cette démocratie maîtrisée fait
naître beaucoup de difficultés de
sécurité.
Et le premier problème des
Mahorais est un problème de
sécurité.
La police et la justice
interviennent.
Sur 60 personnes, 22 ont déjà été
interpellés cette nuit grâce aux
gendarmes et aux policiers dans
les bangas, dans les habitats
insalubres.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
7 secondes, ma chère collègue.
- Emeline K/Bidi: Monsieur le
ministre, l'enfer est pavé de
bonnes intentions.
Ce ne sont pas vos intentions que
nous fustigeons, mais la méthode.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
au président Jean-Paul Mattei pour
le groupe Démocrate.
- Jean-Paul Mattei: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
avez annoncé votre feuille de
route pour les semaines et les
mois à venir.
Le groupe démocrate tient à saluer
votre volonté d'apaisement, de
dialogue, qui a toujours été pour
nous un principe fondateur de
notre démocratie.
La mobilisation l'a démontré hier,
et je veux moi aussi saluer le
courage de nos forces de l'ordre,
qui défendent non seulement la
liberté de manifester, mais aussi
les concitoyens.
L'engagement de réforme est
d'autant plus nécessaire avec
l'annonce de la dégradation de la
notation Fitch de la France.
La réforme de notre système de
retraite est un premier pas
indispensable.
Pour éviter de nous endetter sur
le dos des générations futures.
La clause que nous avons fait
adopter permettra aux partenaires
de se ressaisir dans le respect
démocratique.
Nous devons agir avec plus de
détermination que jamais.
C'est au gouvernement de porter
ces réformes, mais c'est aussi au
gouvernement de retrouver le sens
du dialogue et de travailler avec
toutes les bonnes volontés au-delà
des clans politiques.
Madame la Première ministre,
comment comptez-vous organiser ce
dialogue?
Nous aussi, parlementaires, devons
être aussi entre capacité de faire
ce chemin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, monsieur le
président Jean-Paul Mattei, depuis
6 ans, autour du président de la
République, nous travaillons pour
libérer les énergies, permettre
l'émancipation de chacun,
notamment par le travail, et pour
protéger nos compatriotes.
Depuis près d'un an, malgré une
majorité relative, malgré ceux qui
prédisaient l'immobilisme, malgré
la volonté de blocage de certains,
nous avons avancé.
Déconjugalisation de l'AAH,
maintien du bouclier tarifaire,
lancement du recrutement de
policiers et gendarmes, réforme de
l'assurance chômage, accélération
du nucléaire et des renouvelables,
pérennisation de notre système de
retraite par répartition et
augmentation des plus petites
pensions, voilà un aperçu d'un
bilan solide et concret.
Un bilan qui n'a rien à envier à
d'autres législatures.
Nous devons ce bilan, tout
d'abord, à l'unité et à
l'engagement des trois groupes de
la majorité, que je salue.
Nous le devons aussi à celles et
ceux qui ont travaillé à amender
et construire les textes au-delà
des clivages partisans.
Mesdames et messieurs, nous avons
réussi à bâtir sur des compromis,
voté des réformes et fait faire
des progrès aux Français.
Nous allons continuer à agir face
aux inquiétudes, aux
revendications.
Rien ne serait pire que
l'immobilisme.
La seule manière d'apaiser le
pays, c'est de redoubler d'efforts
pour trouver des solutions
concrètes et relever les grands
défis devant nous.
J'ai présenté une feuille de route
complète la semaine dernière.
Elle apporte des réponses
concrètes aux préoccupations des
Français et les textes dont vous
débattrez en sont l'illustration.
Cette feuille de route, c'est un
appel à toutes les bonnes
volontés.
Parlementaires, élus locaux,
partenaires sociaux.
Nous sommes prêts à agir.
Nous sommes prêts à construire.
Nous avons montré que nous étions
capables de bâtir des compromis et
nous voulons continuer.
Pour répondre aux demandes de nos
concitoyens et préparer l'avenir
de notre pays, nous allons avancer
sur quatre piliers.
Ce sont: le travail, le plein
emploi et la réindustrialisation.
La transition écologique, les
progrès sociaux et l'amélioration
de nos services publics, notamment
la santé et l'éducation, et le
respect de l'ordre républicain.
L'agenda législatif nous permettra
de soutenir ces priorités et nous
devrons, dans le même temps,
réduire notre déficit public et
accélérer notre désendettement.
C'est une condition de notre
indépendance.
Mesdames et messieurs, nous avons
beaucoup à faire pour les
prochains mois.
Nous avons beaucoup de solutions à
apporter, d'inquiétudes à apaiser,
d'inspirations que nous devons
concrétiser.
Au sein de l'arc républicain,
toutes les bonnes volontés sont
les bienvenues.
Depuis un an, je le dis: répondons
à l'appel des Français et
bâtissons ensemble.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
Un peu de silence, s'il vous
plaît.
La parole est à madame Estelle
Youssouffa pour le groupe LIOT.
- Estelle Youssouffa: Je veux dire
ici que notre survie, parce que
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit à
Mayotte, ne peut pas être l'otage
des querelles partisanes.
Depuis plus d'une semaine, des
milliers de Mahorais manifestent à
Mayotte et dans l'Hexagone en
chantant La Marseillaise à pleins
poumons pour réclamer plus de
république et pour soutenir
l'opération Wuambushu pilotée par
le ministre Darmanin, que je
salue.
Nous clamons notre gratitude aux
forces de l'ordre, qui risquent
leur vie à Mayotte pour nous
protéger et faire respecter nos
frontières.
Nous remercions nos policiers et
nos gendarmes, mobilisés pour
lutter contre la criminalité,
contre l'insalubrité des
bidonvilles.
Alors que 75% des Français
soutiennent l'opération Wuambushu,
celle-ci est empêchée par
l'obstruction comorienne, malgré
l'accord passé avec Paris et les
150 millions d'euros que la France
a versés à ce titre.
Les Comores envoient leur
population pour assurer leurs
revendications territoriales.
Le président a condamné
l'opération Wuambushu.
La diplomatie russe offre ses
services pour prendre
militairement Mayotte.
Madame la ministre, nous n'avons
pas entendu un seul mot du Quai
d'Orsay sur cette crise
diplomatique grave.
Pas un mot sur cette ingérence
manifeste dans nos affaires
intérieures.
Quand admettrez-vous enfin
l'inefficacité de 40 ans de
coopération avec Morroni?
Quelle crédibilité pour l'alliance
indo-pacifique si la France
n'arrive pas à défendre son
territoire face aux Comores?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée Estelle
Youssouffa, quelques réalités, si
vous le permettez, car notre
politique concernant Mayotte n'a
qu'un seul objectif: conforter la
place de Mayotte dans la
République.
La ministère de l'Intérieur, comme
le Quai d'Orsay, travaillent
ensemble à ce titre.
Défendre Mayotte, c'est d'abord
réduire la pression migratoire en
provenance des Comores.
L'accord de 2019 permet d'opérer
davantage de reconduite vers tous
les autres pays du monde.
Nous travaillons sans relâche pour
que cela se poursuive.
Le plan de développement de 2019
est un projet pluriannuel qui est
en cours d'exécution.
Il est centré sur la santé et la
formation et permet de lutter
contre les causes profondes des
migrations.
Nous finançons une action pour
protéger Mayotte de l'immigration
clandestine, en empêchant les
départs.
Défendre Mayotte, c'est défendre
la souveraineté de la France dans
ce département.
Depuis 1994, madame la députée,
défendre Mayotte, c'est défendre
son intégration régionale et son
rayonnement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la ministre.
La parole est à madame Cyrielle
Chatelain pour le groupe
écologiste.
- Cyrielle Chatelain: Madame la
Première ministre, depuis 21 ans,
aucune manifestation du 1er mai
n'avait rassemblé autant de
participants.
Si les cortèges se sont déroulés
dans une ambiance conviviale, dans
la majorité des cas, des incidents
se sont déclarés dans plusieurs
villes.
Nous le déplorons et nous
affirmons notre soutien à
l'ensemble des blessés.
Vous espérez que les Français se
démotivent.
Au contraire, nous étions des
millions à dire non à la retraite
à 64 ans, des millions à
revendiquer la hausse des
salaires, des millions pour dire
de respecter.
Nous pourrons répondre à cette
demande des Français, à cette
mobilisation.
Le 8 juin prochain, à l'occasion
de la journée d'initiative
parlementaire du groupe LIOT,
l'Assemblée nationale pourra enfin
voter contre cette réforme.
Vous avez fui le vote.
Vous l'avez empêché.
Le 8 juin, vous ne pourrez pas
vous dérober.
Si cette assemblée adopte la loi,
vous engagez-vous, dès le soir
même, à appliquer cette décision
et à retirer la réforme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
madame la présidente Cyrielle
Chatelain, il y a un peu plus de
deux semaines, le Conseil
constitutionnel a validé
l'essentiel de la réforme des
retraites.
Il a notamment affirmé la pleine
constitutionnalité de la procédure
parlementaire retenue pour faire
face à l'obstruction à laquelle
votre groupe et votre intergroupe
ont participé.
Il a ainsi apporté une réponse
claire, juridique et définitive à
tous les faux procès menés par
certains.
Cette décision a mis fin au chemin
démocratique de cette réforme des
retraites.
Hier, certains de nos concitoyens
sont descendus dans la rue pour
exprimer leurs revendications et
leurs inquiétudes.
Nous devons les entendre, nous
devons leur répondre.
Cette revendication, madame la
présidente Chatelain, dépasse
largement la réforme des
retraites.
Les manifestants, les
travailleurs, les Français,
veulent une meilleure prise en
compte de leurs attentes vis-à-vis
du travail.
Ils veulent des perspectives de
carrière réelles, des engagements
sur la formation ou les
reconversions, des salaires
revalorisés, une prévention de
l'usure professionnelle ou des
mesures sur l'emploi des seniors.
Sur beaucoup de ces sujets, nous
avons déjà agi.
Je rappelle que la réforme des
retraites permet notamment la
création d'un fonds de prévention
de l'usure professionnelle et
prend des mesures pour l'emploi
des seniors.
Nous devons travailler avec les
partenaires sociaux à bâtir un
nouveau pacte de vie au travail.
Madame la présidente Cyrielle
Chatelain, le progrès social ne
viendra pas du bruit des
casseroles, mais bien de l'action
résolue et de la discussion avec
les partenaires sociaux.
C'est le sens de ma feuille de
route.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la Première
ministre.
Madame la présidente?
- Cyrielle Chatelain: Il faudrait
parfois écouter la sagesse des
casseroles qui vous offrent une
porte de sortie.
Retirez votre réforme.
Madame la Première ministre, ne
vous cachez pas derrière le
Conseil constitutionnel.
Il a décidé en droit.
J'attends une réponse politique.
Si, le 8 juin, cette assemblée
abroge la réforme des retraites,
est-ce qu'enfin, vous la retirerez
pour enfin apaiser le pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame la présidente.
La parole est à madame Eléonore
Caroit.
- Eléonore Caroit: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Je remercie mes électeurs qui
m'ont permis d'être parmi vous.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
Comme l'a
indiquée la Première ministre, la
réindustrialisation décarbonée de
notre pays est une priorité de ce
gouvernement.
L'objectif est de renforcer
l'activité de la France et
d'accompagner notre industrie dans
la décarbonation.
La note de la France était
dégradée à cause du déficit, mais
aussi des mouvements sociaux que
connaît notre pays.
Nous mesurons l'impact qu'une
telle décision peut avoir sur le
taux auquel l'Etat emprunte pour
financer la solidarité nationale.
Il nous appartient de restaurer
l'état de nos finances et de mener
une politique ambitieuse pour que
la France soit au rendez-vous des
grands défis du 21e siècle, comme
la transition écologique et
énergétique.
L'investissement public et privé
est essentiel, car il permet la
création et la répartition de la
richesse nationale ainsi que
l'accélération de la transition
écologique.
Aux Etats-Unis, un acte adopté en
août dernier par le Congrès a créé
un cadre incitatif pour favoriser
le développement industriel et
environnemental en pivot
stratégique pour la puissance
américaine.
Nos entreprises aussi ont besoin
d'un cadre incitatif clair et
lisible.
Au niveau français et européen,
nous devons aider les filières
vertes à se développer.
Ce projet sera débattu au
Parlement cet été.
Il devra garantir la protection
des Français et des Françaises, de
leurs emplois dans le cadre de la
réindustrialisation de notre
économie et aussi offrir de
nouvelles opportunités de
formation.
Monsieur le ministre, quelles
actions concrètes proposez-vous
pour bâtir une véritable industrie
verte en France et en Europe?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, madame la
députée, permettez-moi de vous
renouveler toutes mes
félicitations pour votre
réélection, preuve que notre
majorité est vivante et forte.
Le projet de loi industrie verte
que nous allons examiner à
l'Assemblée d'ici quelques
semaines est l'affirmation de la
souveraineté industrielle
européenne et la réponse directe
que nous avons voulu apporter aux
Etats-Unis.
Nous voulons renforcer notre
industrie.
Nous voulons faire avec vous, et
j'ai donc invité l'ensemble des
groupes parlementaires à venir
proposer et compléter le projet
industrie verte dans les jours qui
viennent.
Nous serons très ouverts à chaque
proposition de tous les groupes
pour renforcer notre projet de
loi, dans l'esprit de dialogue qui
a toujours été le nôtre.
Première piste, comment renforcer
le soutien financier comme les
Américains?
Il y a déjà des subventions.
Pourquoi ne pas réfléchir à des
crédits d'impôt?
Deuxième piste, comment favoriser
la commande publique européenne et
la commande publique nationale
pour mieux défendre et mieux
protéger nos intérêts industriels?
Troisième piste, comment accélérer
l'ouverture de nouvelles usines?
Il faut 18 mois en France, et 9
mois en Allemagne.
Nous devons diviser par deux le
délai d'ouverture des usines.
Il faut faire appel à l'épargne
privée des Français.
Dernière piste, la plus capitale
pour notre industrie, la formation
et la qualification des métiers
industriels pour que nous ayons,
demain, des jeunes qui aient la
fierté de travailler dans
l'industrie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Philippe Lottiaux
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Philippe Lottiaux: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Economie des
finances, les agences de notation
sont loin d'avoir toujours raison.
Force est de constater que la
situation est catastrophique.
600 milliards de dettes en plus et
150 milliards de plus par année.
Un déficit record de la balance
commerciale.
L'ensemble de nos services publics
se dégrade, pourtant.
L'inflation pèse sur les classes
moyennes et populaires.
Il y a une impasse politique issue
du passage en force de la réforme
des retraites.
Cela nuit à notre économie.
Vous êtes dans le déni.
Vous avez indiqué vouloir
poursuivre des réformes
structurantes.
Comment mener quelque réforme que
ce soit dans ce contexte?
Comment poursuivre quelque chose
qui n'a pas commencé?
A part entretenir le chaos social,
vous refusez les réformes dont
notre pays a besoin pour
s'apaiser.
Il faut lutter contre les fraudes,
mettre fin à la submersion, sortir
du marché européen de
l'électricité.
Contre l'inflation, vous refusez
de baisser la TVA sur l'énergie et
de la supprimer sur les produits
de première nécessité.
Pour sortir de l'impasse, quand
allez-vous écouter les Français et
prendre les vraies mesures
adoptées par d'autres pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les
députés...
Ne faites pas dire à l'agence de
notation ce qu'elle n'a jamais
dit.
Elle a salué la réforme des
retraites comme une pierre
indispensable au rétablissement
des finances françaises.
Elle regrette uniquement les
blocages et les violences.
J'espère qu'avec nous, vous
regrettez aussi les blocages et
les violences.
Quelle a été notre stratégie?
Nous avons rétabli avec cette
majorité en 2017 et 2018
l'équilibre des finances
publiques.
La bonne gestion des finances
publiques fait partie de l'ADN de
cette majorité.
Nous avons fait face à trois
crises.
Vous-même n'avez cessé de réclamer
des mesures pour protéger nos
compatriotes.
Crise des gilets jaunes, crise du
Covid, qui a été la crise
économique la plus grave que la
France ait eue à affronter depuis
de nombreuses années, crise
économique avec l'inflation...
Monsieur le député, face à ces
crises, nous avons fait le choix
de protéger massivement nos
compatriotes, nos usines, nos
entreprises et nos emplois.
Nous sommes fiers de cette
protection!
Qu'est-ce que vous auriez voulu
que nous
fassions?
Laisser fermer les usines?
Que le chômage explose?
Nous avons fait le choix de la
protection.
Maintenant, nous revenons à la
normale.
Nous allons, avec fermeté,
rigueur, détermination, rétablir
dans les quatre années qui
viennent les finances publiques
françaises.
Nous allons, sous deux ans, sortir
du bouclier sur le gaz, puis du
bouclier sur l'électricité.
Avec ces méthodes, nous allons
revenir sous les 3% du déficit
public en 2027 et baisser la
dette.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
- Philippe Lottiaux: J'ai
l'impression que parfois, vous
créez des crises que vous allez
éteindre après.
Les Français constatent que
finalement, la différence entre
votre gouvernement et le Titanic,
c'est que le Titanic avait un
orchestre, et vous, vous avez des
casseroles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Karen Erodi.
- Karen Erodi: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre délégué aux
Transports, chers collègues.
En avril, une manifestation a eu
lieu sur l'autoroute A69.
"Mettre en place une
infrastructure de qualité, fiable,
durable pour favoriser le
développement économique et le
bien-être de l'être humain à un
coût abordable dans des conditions
d'équité."
Cette autoroute consommera des
millions de mètres cubes d'eau
pour gagner à peine 10 minutes
pour aller dans les bouchons de la
métropole toulousaine, sacrifiant
notre ressource alimentaire.
90% de la population s'y oppose.
L'avis de la commission d'enquête
est défavorable.
Ce dossier s'inscrit dans une
contradiction avec des engagements
nationaux en matière de lutte
contre le changement climatique.
Avec moins de 600 véhicules par
jour, cette concession sera
déficitaire.
Vous refusez encore de rendre
public le contrat de concession.
Qui va payer?
Où est l'intérêt général?
17 euros aller-retour, ce sera
l'autoroute des riches.
Le gagnant de cette opération,
c'est celui qui l'organise.
Cette autoroute est inutile.
Allez-vous respecter votre
engagement à revoir le projet en
cours?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Madame la
députée, je voudrais avoir un mot
pour le préfet du Tarn, les
services de l'Etat et les
associations qui ont été
responsables et qui, par le
dialogue, ont permis que la
manifestation puisse se dérouler
dans le calme.
Je salue aussi votre intérêt que
je découvre pour ce projet.
Avant les manifestations, vous
n'avez jamais sollicité de
questions sur ce projet.
Puisque vous m'interrogez,
parlons-en.
Je veux souligner l'état
d'avancement de ce projet.
Il a fait l'objet de recours.
Nous sommes en état de droit.
Tous ont été déboutés par la
justice.
Les travaux de ce projet ont
commencé.
Ce n'est plus vraiment un projet,
mais un début de réalisation.
Est-ce que cela veut dire que les
choses ne peuvent pas s'améliorer?
Qu'on ne peut pas en discuter?
Je ne crois pas.
Mon ministère a pris l'initiative
de réduire les impacts écologiques
significativement.
Nous pouvons faire mieux et je
suis prêt à discuter.
J'en ai discuté déjà avec les élus
du département qui se sont
exprimés dans une très large
majorité pour ce projet.
Je pense au président socialiste
de ce département, à la présidente
de la région Occitanie.
Vous m'interrogez sur les
engagements.
Nous examinons chacun des projets
en cours avec les engagements pris
et les impacts environnementaux en
suivant le conseil d'orientation.
Nous allons prendre des décisions
courageuses et audacieuses dans
les prochains mois.
Certains projets seront peut-être
mis à l'arrêt.
Faites preuve d'un esprit
constructif à cet égard.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Philippe Brun pour le
groupe socialiste.
- Philippe Brun: Madame la
Première ministre, dans une
interview au Figaro du lundi 24
avril, le président de la
République demandait aux Français
d'être patients et d'attendre la
fin de l'été afin de voir
l'inflation baisser.
Jusqu'à quand, enfin,
abuserez-vous de la patience des
Français?
Explosion des prix en février,
explosion des prix alimentaires...
Face à cette explosion des prix,
les mesures du gouvernement
s'avèrent insuffisantes.
Augmentation résiduelle du SMIC à
hauteur de 2,2%!
Augmentations indignes des minima
sociaux à seulement 1,6%!
Aujourd'hui, une mère célibataire
avec deux enfants voit son pouvoir
d'achat diminuer chaque mois de
270 euros.
Insuffisantes sont les mesures
prises contre la hausse des prix
alimentaires.
Je pense à votre panier.
Que dire de ce bouclier tarifaire
dont vous avez annoncé
l'extinction et qui constitue une
subvention au marché de
l'électricité?
Notre question est la suivante:
allez-vous prendre enfin à
bras-le-corps la question de
l'augmentation des prix?
Blocage des prix des produits de
première nécessité, grande
conférence nationale sur les
salaires, suspension de la hausse
des prix de l'électricité et
fixation des prix sur celui de la
production.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, mon
cher collègue.
La parole est à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le député
Philippe Brun.
On voudrait bien vous entendre, si
vous n'aviez pas multiplié au
cours des derniers mois les
propositions qui réduisent le
pouvoir d'achat de nos
compatriotes et refusé de voter
les propositions qui protègent le
pouvoir d'achat de nos
compatriotes.
Vous avez proposé de supprimer la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires.
Ca veut dire que vous réduisez le
pouvoir d'achat de ceux qui
travaillent, et vous retirez 150
euros par année à un salarié qui
travaille 12 mois par an et qui
gagne 1200 euros par mois.
Vous avez proposé de supprimer les
exonérations de cotisations pour
les bas salaires, pour tous les
commerçants, artisans, et c'est un
retrait de pouvoir d'achat, une
diminution des revenus de ceux qui
travaillent.
Nous avons proposé et adopté
l'indemnité carburant travailleur
de 100 euros pour ceux qui
prennent le véhicule pour aller
travailler.
Vous ne l'avez pas voté.
Vous n'avez voté aucune des
mesures qui améliorent le pouvoir
d'achat de nos compatriotes, donc
ne nous donnez pas de leçons.
Cette majorité est celle qui a le
mieux protégé nos compatriotes
contre l'inflation de tous les
pays européens.
Il reste les prix alimentaires.
Nous prenons le sujet à
bras-le-corps avec Olivier
Grégoire.
Nous réunirons très prochainement
l'ensemble des acteurs de la
distribution pour voir avec eux
comment aller plus loin et
protéger contre l'inflation nos
compatriotes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à
notre groupe Renaissance.
- Nous avons tous en tête les
images de violence contre les
forces de l'ordre.
Je voudrais rendre hommage aux 406
gendarmes et policiers blessés
hier lors des manifestations et
condamner la violence.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer.
La lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiants est un enjeu de santé
publique, de sécurité, mais aussi
de société.
Cela impacte le décrochage
scolaire.
Il oppose le mirage de l'égalité
des chances face à l'argent
facile.
Cette activité criminelle irrigue
toutes les autres et alimente le
développement du narco-banditisme.
Le gouvernement a agi à plusieurs
niveaux: la création de l'Office
anti-stupéfiants, la mise en place
de cellules de renseignement
opérationnelles sur les
stupéfiants dans chaque
département et la généralisation
de l'amende forfaitaire.
La légalisation qui a eu lieu dans
certains états n'a pas fait ses
preuves.
En France, elle serait un
renoncement.
L'Etat met en place des mesures
inédites.
Le volet sécurité et la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur viennent
considérablement enrayer les
dynamiques de ces trafics, à
l'heure où le trafic n'a jamais
été aussi vif.
Pouvez-vous rappeler devant la
représentation nationale la
feuille de route et les objectifs
du gouvernement en matière de
lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Je veux saluer le travail de
l'ensemble des élus marseillais et
le vôtre, celui des parlementaires
aussi, et du maire de Marseille.
A Marseille, il y a
malheureusement de la drogue, dans
tous les quartiers de la ville.
Marseille doit retrouver de la
quiétude.
En un an, 40 points de deal ont
été annulés.
Le trafic de drogue a été calmé.
Nous mettons des centaines de
policiers et de gendarmes
supplémentaires qui interviennent
contre les points de deal.
570 gardes à vue depuis le 1er
janvier, et énormément de police
judiciaire.
Ces attaques provoquent des
règlements de compte.
Les conquêtes de territoires sont
très fortes.
Nous avons face à nous des gens
qui sont très armés et puissants.
La puissance de l'Etat sera
d'autant plus forte, que la ville
va augmenter les caméras de
vidéosurveillance.
Vous avez décidé avec le président
de la République de permettre à la
ville de Marseille de mieux vivre.
C'est très difficile, j'en
conviens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Eric Ciotti.
- Eric Ciotti: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Avant d'évoquer la situation à
Mayotte, permettez-moi, au nom des
députés Les Républicains,
d'exprimer ma reconnaissance et
mon soutien aux policiers qui ont
été blessés hier lors des
manifestations, victimes de la
violence de l'extrême gauche.
Madame la Première ministre,
Mayotte vit depuis des semaines
une situation totalement
insupportable.
Violences, pillages, guet-apens
sont le lot quotidien de la
population.
Cela est dû à une immigration
totalement hors de contrôle qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui, il y a plus
d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière à Mayotte que de
citoyens de la République
française.
Cette situation a été appelée à la
demande des élus.
Cette opération, nous la
soutenons.
Je le dis sans réserve.
Elle est essentielle et elle est
importante.
Aujourd'hui, face au courage de la
population et de sa résilience, la
République ne peut pas reculer.
Cette opération est à l'arrêt à
cause d'une décision judiciaire
aux motivations totalement
ahurissantes, mais aussi devant la
force qu'expriment les Comores face
à la volonté de la République
française.
La République ne peut pas reculer.
Le drapeau français doit continuer
à flotter sur Mayotte pour dire
que l'immigration illégale n'a pas
sa place sur notre territoire et
pour faire en sorte que demain, la
métropole ne subisse pas la
situation que subit Mayotte
aujourd'hui.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Monsieur le président Ciotti,
merci de votre soutien.
Je voudrais saluer vos camarades
mahorais.
Cette opération, c'est des
gendarmes mobiles, quatre unités
supplémentaires, une unité de CRS,
mais aussi des magistrats, des
agents du ministère de la Santé...
Un renforcement sans précédent de
la République.
Pour vous répondre, à l'histoire
très particulière de Mayotte qui
est faite à la fois de longs
renoncements de la République et
aussi d'une situation très
difficile...
On a évoqué la démocratie qui
n'est pas maîtrisée sur le
territoire mahorais.
Vous dites que la République ne
doit pas reculer, vous avez
raison.
La République ne reculera pas.
Nous laisserons les gendarmes
mobiles et les policiers autant de
temps qu'il le faudra à Mayotte.
Nous avons trois objectifs.
Le premier, c'est l'interpellation
des criminels.
Cette opération est en train
d'être réussie du point de vue de
la délinquance.
Ensuite, il y a eu une décision de
justice négative et il y a eu une
centaine de décisions de justice
positives pour l'action du préfet
de Mayotte qui fait un travail
formidable.
Nous aurons la réponse demain sur
d'autres sujets.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Benjamin Lucas.
- Merci.
Je veux lancer un fonds qui
s'appellera le fonds Marianne.
Ma première question est la
suivante: qu'avez-vous fait des
2,5 millions d'euros et quel a été
leur impact pour défendre les
valeurs de la République?
La question est légitime, car
depuis, plusieurs médias ont
révélé que ce sont vos proches qui
auraient touché des dizaines de
milliers d'euros.
C'est moralement et juridiquement
condamnable.
Singulièrement au moment où tant
de nos associations souffrent de
financement et où certaines
d'entre elles sont criminalisées
dans le cadre de votre loi
séparatiste.
Cette association fictive était
des officines destinées à salir
vos opposants politiques et à
influencer les résultats des
élections présidentielles et
législatives.
Démocratiquement, moralement et
juridiquement, c'est condamnable.
Quel a été le rôle de madame
Marlène Schiappa dans ce scandale
d'Etat?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur Benjamin
Lucas.
Veuillez excuser l'absence de la
secrétaire d'Etat qui remplace
madame Schiappa et qui a saisi
l'inspection générale et le
procureur de la République
lorsqu'elle a eu vent de cette
affaire.
Les deux associations que vous
évoquez ont été mises en cause.
Le rapport sera rendu fin juin.
Le rapport sera rendu public au
Parlement.
Le Sénat a fait savoir qu'il y
aura une commission d'enquête.
Le gouvernement a déjà fourni aux
deux commissions, et notamment à
monsieur Coquerel, les documents
comptables.
Je m'étonne que vous n'ayez pas
fait référence à ces documents.
Je veux dire mon soutien à la
ministre Marlène Schiappa.
Non, ce ne sont pas nos amis.
Je n'ai pas reçu les personnes
évoquées dans la presse.
Je n'ai jamais dîné au déjeuner
avec eux.
Evitez de faire des comparaisons.
Sur la communication pour gagner
les élections, c'est une
association qui a fait de nombreux
tweets pour m'insulter
personnellement.
C'est assez partagé.
Qu'il y ait eu un
dysfonctionnement, nous allons
voir ce que va dire le procureur
de la République.
Le rapport qui sera public et la
commission d'enquête prendront les
sanctions nécessaires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Benjamin Lucas: Si dans 200 ans,
des historiens veulent décrire le
macronisme, ils diront qu'il est
né avant la honte.
Vous avez sali la mémoire de
Samuel Paty qui appelle à la
décence et la dignité!
Tout témoigne du fait que vous
manquez d'impartialité dans la
conduite des affaires de l'Etat!
Tout témoigne du fait que vous
salissez les institutions!
C'est criminel.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Hubert Wulfranc.
- Hubert Wulfranc: Non, la page
n'est pas tournée.
Une mobilisation historique le 1er
mai, un référendum toujours
possible, et, dès début juin, 48
heures où vont à nouveau se
conjuguer mouvement social et
initiative parlementaire afin
d'abroger votre projet de retraite
à 64 ans.
Voilà de quoi occuper vos 100
jours.
Vous allez continuer à traîner
cette casserole avec d'autres, la
vie chère, les salaires bloqués...
100 jours pour que la majorité des
Français qui s'y opposent, à cette
réforme, décrochent la timbale de
son retrait.
Et comme cette réforme n'a pour
but que de donner satisfaction aux
marchés financiers et à l'Europe
libérale, un conseil: arrêtez tout
de suite de vouloir charger la
barque.
En effet, rumeur ou par rumeur, et
malgré les propos sur la petite
gaspille, tout à l'heure défendue
par monsieur Bruno Le Maire, vous
préparerez bel et bien,
méthodiquement et précisément,
mécaniquement, la baisse de 5 %
des dépenses utiles de l'Etat.
Santé, éducation, logement,
environnement...
Et toujours sans envisager un seul
instant de dégager des recettes
sur les aides publiques aux
grandes entreprises ou de mettre à
contribution leurs profits.
Ma question est simple: êtes-vous
définitivement adeptes de la
politique de la terre brûlée
sociale?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député Wulfranc, permettez-moi,
avant de répondre à votre question
sur la politique sociale, de
m'adresser à vous et aux militants
du Parti Communiste qui ont été
pris à partie hier dans les
manifestations.
Nous adressons notre soutien à vos
militants et à vos dirigeants.
Je ne partage en revanche pas
l'orientation de votre question.
Le gouvernement mène une réforme
des retraites qui a fait l'objet
d'une concertation, puis d'un
débat au Parlement pendant presque
200 heures, qui a permis d'avancer
et qui a permis d'avoir un texte
meilleur que celui que nous
aurions pu présenter il y a
plusieurs mois.
Nous sommes extrêmement attentifs
aux conditions de mise en oeuvre
de cette réforme.
D'autres mesures vont entrer en
vigueur, autres que le recul de
l'âge.
La mise en place du fonds
d'investissement à l'usure
professionnelle, la création de
l'ouverture de la retraite
progressive à la fonction
publique, dont elle était
jusqu'alors privée, et la
simplification de l'accès des
salariés du secteur privé à cette
même retraite progressive.
Travaillant pour que ces mesures
soient mises en place au mois de
septembre et que l'équilibre que
nous avons recherché soit au
rendez-vous.
Evidemment, que la réforme reste.
Vous avez dit que c'était un
sparadrap.
Elle ne doit pas nous empêcher de
travailler.
Elle ne doit pas nous empêcher
d'avancer.
Nous avons dit avec madame la
Première ministre la disponibilité
du gouvernement pour avoir des
négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux sur de nombreux sujets.
Nous espérons bâtir un agenda
social pour le début de l'été.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Nicolas Pacquot pour le
groupe Renaissance.
- Nicolas Pacquot: Hier, nous
avons fêté le travail dans un
contexte où le plein emploi est à
portée de main.
Depuis 2017, nous avons recréé 1,7
million d'emplois.
Nous avons relocalisé des
industries.
Nous avons investi massivement
dans l'apprentissage.
Nous continuons à avancer au
service de la France et des
Français pour que le redressement
de notre pays se poursuive et ce,
même si certains tapent sur des
casseroles.
Plus grave, hier, les domiciles
privés de parlementaires de la
majorité ont été visés.
Permettez-moi, madame la
présidente, d'apporter tout mon
soutien à mes collègues et à leurs
familles.
Plus que du bruit des casseroles,
j'aimerais vous parler de ces
entreprises industrielles qui les
conçoivent, les fabriquent, dont
un fleuron industriel de mon
territoire.
Nous avons pu le visiter récemment
avec ma collègue, Aurore Bergé.
Une centaine de salariés au
savoir-faire d'exception, tous
attachés à l'entreprise, fiers de
créer l'excellence de la marque.
Ce sont des dirigeants qui ont
pris tous les risques pour
reprendre cette entreprise,
devenue entreprise forte, leader
en articles culinaires haut de
gamme.
Parlons de ces hommes et de ces
femmes, chefs d'entreprise et
salariés.
Soyons fiers de nos entreprises.
Ils sont tous les acteurs de la
compétitivité retrouvée.
J'aimerais savoir quelles mesures
concrètes envisagez-vous pour
encourager les entreprises qui
font des profits à mieux rémunérer
leurs salariés?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
au ministre du Travail, du Plein
emploi et de l'Insertion.
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député Pacquot, je partage avec
vous une satisfaction collective:
l'économie française, depuis 2017,
a créé 1,7 millions d'emplois.
Le chômage est passé de 9,5% à
7,2%.
C'est un emploi de bonne qualité.
Il faut que le plein emploi soit
synonyme de bon emploi.
Il faut veiller à la bonne mise en
oeuvre d'un texte que la majorité
présidentielle a voté avec le
renfort de ceux qui l'ont
souhaité.
Pour faire en sorte que la prime
de partage de la valeur soit
pérennisée et la rendre
incitative.
Ce texte est un bon texte pour
permettre à toutes les entreprises
qui le souhaitent d'avancer et de
faciliter le partage de la valeur
à leur échelle avec des conditions
de souplesse intéressantes.
Nous voulons également que la
dynamique des négociations
salariales dans les branches soit
bien présente.
L'obligation est renforcée par la
loi de juillet, que j'ai fait
voter.
Je réunirai prochainement le
comité de suivi des négociations
salariales pour garantir la bonne
application et l'ouverture des
négociations salariales, branche
par branche.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Annie
Genevard pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Annie Genevard: La politique de
votre ministre de l'Education
nationale concernant
l'enseignement privé est
dangereuse.
Un ministre de l'Education
nationale devrait s'attaquer aux
maux qui rongent l'école publique,
au niveau des élèves qui se
dégrade, comme en attestent toutes
les évaluations, les attaques en
règle contre la laïcité d'un
islamisme conquérant, le
harcèlement scolaire qui tue, mais
il a choisi de s'en prendre à
l'école privée.
Le moyen de résoudre ces
problèmes?
L'obligation de mixité sociale.
Comme si celle-ci n'existait pas
dans le privé.
Cette politique pétrie d'idéologie
est assortie de menaces non
dissimulées.
Si les écoles privées ne se plient
pas à ce nouveau diktat, le
ministre a récemment déclaré sur
une radio de service public que
les moyens seraient diminués pour
les récalcitrants.
Quelle valeur peut avoir un
protocole signé sous une telle
menace?
Je passe sur la méconnaissance de
la réalité de l'immense majorité
de ces établissements privés de
province qui scolarisent des
enfants venus de tous les milieux.
Pour quelques établissements
publics ou privés qui ont choisi
d'opérer un recrutement fondé sur
l'excellence, dont notre pays a
besoin,
vous risquez de rallumer une
guerre scolaire.
Plus grave, vous passez à côté du
seul combat qui vaille: offrir à
tous les enfants un enseignement
de qualité dans un environnement
paisible.
Madame la Première ministre, n'y
a-t-il pas mieux à faire pour
restaurer l'école publique que de
mettre à mal la liberté de l'école
privée?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est au ministre de
l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
madame la députée Genevard, les
craintes que vous exprimez sont
très largement infondées et je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
D'abord, parce que les questions
de mixité sont des questions qui
sont relatives au niveau scolaire.
Il y a des études, toutes
convergentes, qui montrent que, en
France ou ailleurs, favoriser la
mixité, c'est améliorer le niveau
scolaire, et aussi améliorer le
climat scolaire.
On pourrait même dire: améliorer
le climat social en général.
Or, la situation française n'est
pas tout à fait satisfaisante à
cet égard.
Nous donnons la priorité, lorsque
nous réfléchissons à ces
questions, au public.
Nous avons permis d'augmenter
significativement le taux de
boursiers dans des établissements
qui en recevaient peu.
C'est le cas au lycée Henri IV et
au lycée Louis Le Grand.
Nous réfléchissons également, avec
les collectivités, à améliorer la
sectorisation, à implanter des
filières d'excellence là où il n'y
en a pas.
Les acteurs du privé sont
également demandeurs de travailler
avec nous dans le respect du libre
choix des familles.
Dans le respect du libre choix des
familles, monsieur le député, je
le confirme.
Nous sommes en échange très
constructif avec un certain nombre
de ces acteurs, dont le
secrétariat général de
l'enseignement catholique, et nous
sommes d'accord sur beaucoup de
points.
Je ne vois pas pourquoi il
faudrait, de votre côté, être plus
royaliste que le roi.
Il n'y a pas de guerre que je
connaisse qui commence par un
protocole de paix.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
Madame la députée?
- Annie Genevard: Je vous ai
entendu sur France Inter.
Vous avez dit: "Si les
établissements privés ne
respectent pas la mixité sociale,
nous leur diminuerons leurs moyens
en termes de ressources humaines."
Vous l'avez dit!
Est-ce que ça s'appelle un
dialogue constructif avec l'école
privée?
Je ne le crois pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, ma chère collègue.
La parole est à monsieur Roger
Vicot pour le groupe socialiste.
- Roger Vicot: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Depuis plusieurs mois, les
nombreuses et massives
manifestations qui se déroulent
dans notre pays, en opposition à
la réforme des retraites, ont mis
en lumière un autre débat qui a
été évoqué plusieurs fois cet
après-midi, celui de la doctrine
d'emploi des forces de l'ordre et
de la violence qui, de part et
d'autre, accompagne souvent ces
marches populaires.
Nous condamnons sans nuance toutes
les violences, d'où qu'elles
viennent.
Il est absolument indiscutable que
des fauteurs de troubles,
particulièrement bien organisés,
se sont attaqués ces dernières
semaines à la police nationale,
considérée par eux comme une cible
privilégiée.
C'est bien sûr à la fois
scandaleux et inacceptable.
Hier encore, plusieurs centaines
de policiers en ont été les
victimes, vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure.
Il est aussi indiscutable que
certains membres de la police
nationale ont adopté un
comportement que je considère
comme indigne de leur fonction et
indigne des valeurs qu'ils sont
censés porter au sein de notre
Républicains.
Les médias ont largement relayé
des images de manifestants
pacifiques, syndicalistes,
retraités, salariés, étudiants,
parfois des familles, aveuglément
molestés dans une stratégie
droitière de l'ordre, qui nous
apparaît aujourd'hui comme à la
fois nébuleuse et incertaine.
A travers ces dérives, certes
exceptionnelles, la liberté de
manifester est mise en cause.
Et ce faisant, toutes les valeurs
sur lesquelles s'appuie notre
pacte républicain.
Monsieur le ministre, pouvez-vous
nous éclairer sur ce point?
Ces policiers agissent-ils au coup
par coup, spontanément, de manière
autonome, ou obéissent-ils à des
instructions précises qui
participent à l'escalade de la
violence?
Dans l'un ou l'autre cas, ça pose
problème.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est au porte-parole du
gouvernement.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Merci d'avoir condamné les
violences constatées dans
certaines villes de France à
l'occasion de ces manifestations.
Je ne partage pas du tout ce que
dit monsieur Mélenchon quand il
parle de "mauvaise République".
Il n'y a pas de bonne et de
mauvaise République.
Par contre, il y a sans doute des
bons et des mauvais manifestants.
Les bons manifestants viennent
avec une revendication sociale un
1er mai ou en manifestation,
manifestent parfois en famille ou
entre collègues et veulent faire
passer un message dans la parole
publique.
Le mauvais manifestant se moque
totalement de la cause à laquelle
vient manifester, mais vient armé
de barres de fer et de boules de
pétanque et vient pour en
découdre.
Le premier objectif que nous
avons, c'est de garantir la
sécurité des manifestants pour que
les bons manifestants qui viennent
manifester puissent le faire dans
de bonnes conditions de sécurité.
Je me mets à la place d'un CRS,
d'un policier ou d'un gendarme,
qui reçoit des boules de pétanque,
parfois des bidons d'essence et
des cocktails Molotov, comme on
l'a vu, et qui arrive à conserver
son calme, son professionnalisme
pour s'orienter et orienter son
action vers la protection des
Français qui manifestent librement
dans nos rues.
Ce qui me choque, avant tout,
c'est d'abord cela.
J'aimerais bien des prises de
parole qui condamnent d'abord ceux
qui agressent les policiers, avant
de commencer à les condamner eux.
Les policiers sont porteurs de
l'autorité de la République.
Ils représentent la République
pour tous les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur William
Martinet pour La France Insoumise.
- William Martin: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre des
Solidarités, Jean-Christophe
Combe.
Une enfant de 11 mois est décédée
des suites d'un empoisonnement
dans une crèche.
Ce drame a libéré la parole des
parents et des professionnels
concernant la maltraitance des
enfants au sein des crèches
privées et lucratives.
Humiliations, privations,
violences verbales ou physiques,
des plaintes ont été déposées pour
dénoncer ces abus.
Je salue le courage des parents
qui engagent ces procédures
longues et éprouvantes.
Ils agissent au nom de l'intérêt
général.
Je vous propose de vous inspirer
du courage de ces parents,
monsieur le ministre.
Il est temps de décider que la
marchandisation du secteur de
l'enfance est une folie.
Ces crèches privées sont arrosées
de subventions qui payent les
dividendes des actionnaires.
Nous sommes bien éloignés de la
puériculture.
L'exigence de la rentabilité de
ces fonds d'investissement se
répercute sur la gestion des
crèches.
Des personnels non-qualifiés sont
recrutés.
Les taux d'encadrement ne sont pas
respectés.
Des économies sont faites à tout
prix.
2 couches maximum par jour, a
témoigné une professionnelle.
Monsieur le ministre, votre propre
administration tire la sonnette
d'alarme en dénonçant des dérives
inacceptables, car elles suivent
une logique exclusivement
financière.
Le parallèle est fait entre les
crèches lucratives et le scandale
des EHPAD.
Il est temps d'agir.
Allez vous mettre un terme à ce
système qui maltraite nos enfants
au nom de l'argent roi?
Allez-vous bâtir un véritable
service public de la petite
enfance?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-Christophe Combe,
ministre des Solidarités, de
l'autonomie des personnes
handicapées.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Monsieur
le député Martinet, votre question
me permet de revenir sur le bon
rapport que l'Inspection générale
des affaires sociales m'a remis,
que j'avais moi-même diligenté en
janvier, peu après ma nomination.
Il faisait suite au drame
épouvantable qui était intervenu
dans une crèche à Lyon.
Une petite fille avait perdu la
vie.
De nombreux dysfonctionnements
nous sont remontés depuis.
Le rapport fait des constats
extrêmement forts.
Il décrit d'abord des situations
très hétérogènes.
Vous décrivez une situation très
noire, mais, dans la grande
majorité des cas, les
professionnels exercent leurs
fonctions dans de bonnes
conditions.
Je voudrais saluer leur
engagement.
La grande majorité des crèches
dans notre pays assurent l'accueil
et la sécurité des enfants.
Il dit aussi qu'on a une
intégration bien insuffisante des
connaissances autour du jeune
enfant et dans la formation des
professionnels, mais aussi dans la
gestion éducative des
établissements.
Il revient sur l'insuffisance de
certaines règles de financement et
de contrôle.
Les 39 propositions du contrôle
sont actuellement en cours
d'expertise.
Je m'engage à y donner suite dans
les semaines qui viennent.
Il s'agit notamment de la sécurité
et de l'accueil dans les crèches,
dans le public, l'associatif ou le
privé.
Dans la continuité de la charte de
l'accueil, qui avait été instituée
à l'occasion de la législature
précédente...
Je tiens à le dire, les
dysfonctionnements sont partout et
pas seulement dans les groupes que
vous évoquez.
Nous y travaillerons dans le cadre
de la mise en place du service
public de la petite enfance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Blanchet
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Christophe Blanchet: Le séjour
des jeunes du SNU, c'est terminé.
Un témoignage: "Au début, ça ne
m'a pas plu.
Au final, je trouve ça bien.
Au lever, on est tous ensemble et
les encadrants sont tops."
Emmener les jeunes vers d'autres
horizons, les sortir de leurs
habitudes et leur donner des
repères patriotiques qui font la
cohésion nationale, pour apprendre
à aimer la France, c'est ça aussi,
le SNU.
Pour autant, ces jeunes,
majoritairement volontaires, m'ont
dit que le SNU devait rester
incitatif, pour l'instant.
Il doit apparaître comme une
opportunité et non comme une
contrainte.
Comme une chance, plutôt que comme
une obligation.
Pour respecter cette vision,
investir dans la fidélisation des
encadrants est primordial.
Je voudrais saluer les
professionnels qui prennent sur
leur temps et qui sont la main du
service national universel.
Ne peut-on pas penser autrement en
mutualisant les futurs centres de
réservistes dans chaque
département pour accueillir des
jeunes du SNU?
Madame la ministre, quelle est
votre feuille de route?
Accueillons tous les jeunes, à
l'avenir, qui le veulent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à la secrétaire d'Etat chargée de
la Jeunesse et du service national
universel.
- Sarah El Haïry: Mesdames,
messieurs les députés, monsieur le
député Blanchet, je voudrais
saluer votre engagement auprès des
jeunes du service national
universel.
Vous accompagnez ces séjours.
Je profite de cette prise de
parole pour inviter l'ensemble des
parlementaires, quel que soit leur
banc, à venir dans ces centres, à
aller à l'encontre des encadrants
et de ces jeunes pour voir à quel
point ce projet est émancipateur
et permet de la mixité.
Loin des caricatures et du travail
de sape que le service national
universel subit, il faut bien sûr
accompagner son développement,
faire en sorte que ce SNU fasse
grandir leur amour dans la France
et leur fasse vivre des moments
patriotiques.
Et aussi: de se découvrir
autrement, d'avoir plus confiance
en eux, de découvrir les gestes
qui sauvent, la rénovation des
chantiers de patrimoine, des
questions de santé...
Votre question est très claire:
comment pérenniser?
Quel est le cap?
La mission que le président de la
République m'a donnée est de
permettre que cette chance soit
une chance pour tous.
C'est ce que nous faisons, avec le
ministre de l'Education nationale
et le ministre des Armées.
Sous l'autorité de la Première
ministre, j'ai la mission de
renforcer la question logistique
du service national universel.
Il faut l'ancrer sur notre
territoire pour que ce soit une
chance pour nos jeunes et aussi
pour nos territoires.
Nous travaillons à ce que chaque
élu qui souhaite présenter un
bâtiment, puisse accueillir demain
des centres permettant aux jeunes
d'être accueillis tout au long de
l'année et puisse évidemment
postuler.
Demain, les jeunes pourront être
accueillis, je l'espère, tout au
long de l'année, avec des
encadrants fidélisés.
La qualité passera par la qualité
des encadrants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Fabrice Brun pour le
groupe Les Républicains.
- Fabrice Brun: Monsieur le
ministre de la Santé, vous avez
affirmé, début avril, qu'aucun
service ne fermerait.
Depuis, des hôpitaux sont, pour la
première fois, contraints de
fermer les urgences la nuit, faute
de médecins.
Les habitants subissent les
conséquences de ces fermetures.
Cela ne peut plus durer dans un
pays qui consacre autant à ses
dépenses de santé.
Venez à Aubenas, mesurez que,
malgré ses bons sentiments, la loi
Rist augmente encore les
inégalités territoriales pour les
hôpitaux et éloigne des CHU et des
grandes agglomérations.
Nous ne formons toujours pas de
médecins et de soignants.
Il faut faire confiance aux jeunes
Français méritants, contraints
aujourd'hui de s'expatrier pour
étudier.
L'attractivité des métiers du
soin, c'est ce que nous proposons.
Régulation, réquisition,
interdiction du remplacement dans
le privé pour les mercenaires,
voilà des mesures fortes.
Pourtant, rien de tout ça n'est
dans la feuille de route du
gouvernement, annoncée la semaine
dernière.
Il y a urgence!
Répondez-nous enfin avec du
concret.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur François Braun,
ministre de la Santé.
- François Braun: Monsieur le
député, depuis un mois, nous
mettons en application une loi qui
a été votée dans cet hémicycle, la
loi Rist, dont vous parlez.
Il était temps de la mettre en
application, car elle limite les
dérives.
Ces limites sont une plaie pour le
service public hospitalier et
contribuent largement à la chute des
médecins de notre hôpital public.
Cette mise en application de la
loi se conjugue également avec un
renforcement de l'attractivité des
carrières des praticiens
hospitaliers, qu'il faut maintenir
à l'hôpital.
C'est la colonne vertébrale de
notre service public hospitalier.
Dans tous les territoires, les ARS
ont mis en application, territoire
par territoire, des solutions
alternatives pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de rupture de la chaîne des
soins.
C'est le cas aussi à Aubenas.
Le service doit fermer la nuit,
mais il était déjà en grande
difficulté avant même
l'application de la loi Rist.
Les solutions mises en place
permettent de garantir la prise en
charge des urgences vitales par le
maintien d'une ligne de SMUR et
l'ajout d'une ligne supplémentaire
au niveau du territoire pour les
transferts secondaires.
Egalement, le soutien des
sapeurs-pompiers par la mise en
place d'une équipe de soutien.
Ce sont des mesures concrètes pour
améliorer les choses.
D'ores et déjà, les anesthésistes
qui manquaient à l'hôpital sont
revenus.
Nous en avons un nombre suffisant.
Je ne doute pas que ce soit aussi
rapidement le cas pour les
urgences.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Fabrice Brun: Je ne remets pas
en cause votre volonté d'avancer
mais il y a apparemment un
décalage entre vos informations et
la réalité sur le terrain.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Alexis Jolly.
- Alexis Jolly: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie, des Finances et de
l'industrie du numérique.
Le bilan du gouvernement en
matière de pilotage est absolument
désastreux.
L'histoire récente de l'entreprise
photovolataïque est un exemple
criant.
Cette entreprise devrait se porter
à merveille puisque l'Etat aurait
pu se fournir en panneaux solaires
pour alimenter la nouvelle
centrale solaire qui est à 30 km à
vol d'oiseau.
Cette ancienne industrie française
fermée pour plaire aux lobbys
écologistes a pourtant été équipée
de 22.000 panneaux solaires
chinois.
L'entreprise ne trouve toujours
pas de repreneur.
Une fois encore, notre industrie
est en danger.
Ces situations se multiplient
partout sur le territoire.
Nous sommes en face d'une
prédation qui est mise en place
contre notre industrie, alors que
l'Etat tente de défendre nos
intérêts nationaux.
Je souhaite savoir quand votre
gouvernement va se décider à
protéger les entreprises
stratégiques et les emplois
français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Olivia Grégoire, ministre
chargée de l'Artisanat et du
Tourisme.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Alexis Jolly,
votre question est très
directement une question relative
à notre industrie.
Ce n'est pas Bruno Le Maire, mais
Roland Lescure qui est en débat à
la chambre haute.
Quant à vos commentaires sur Bruno
Le Maire, ils vous appartiennent.
Concernant
l'entreprise dont vous parlez,
pour ceux qui seraient intéressés
par une réponse pour cette
question, c'est une entreprise
importante, une des dernières
impliquées dans la fabrication des
panneaux solaires.
Elle a connu une période faste au
début des années 2000, alors
qu'elle était le troisième
fabricant mondial avec 1200
salariés.
Le dumping asiatique a conduit au
fait que la fermeture a été
évitée.
Il y a un problème de
compétitivité sur ce marché qui
est très tendu.
L'entreprise ne dispose pas de la
taille qui convient pour
rentabiliser les grands
investissements qui sont lourds et
qui sont nécessaires.
L'entreprise ne compte plus que
180 salariés au moment où je vous
parle.
La filiale du photovoltaïque est
stratégique.
C'est pour cela que vous trouverez
dans le plan France 2030 un budget
dédié au photovoltaïque.
Nous avons plusieurs projets à
l'étude dans ce sens et un projet
de loi qui arrive.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Christine Le
Nabour.
- Christine Le Nabour: Ma question
s'adresse à la ministre chargée
des Personnes handicapées.
Le ministère a tracé une feuille
de route pour l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement.
C'était l'occasion de faire le
bilan sur les actions menées
depuis 2017 et de préparer la
sixième conférence nationale du
handicap.
Plus de 500 personnes ont
participé à des groupes de
travail.
Des personnes en situation de
handicap, des élus locaux, des
entreprises, des opérateurs de
transport, des parlementaires et
des administrations.
Une véritable co-construction.
Ces travaux ont mobilisé
l'ensemble des expertises d'usage
du secteur pour construire des
solutions dans chaque aspect de la
vie quotidienne, l'école, l'accès
à l'emploi, la santé, le logement,
et les loisirs.
En avril dernier a eu lieu la
conférence nationale du handicap.
Le ministre des Solidarités, le
président de la République et
vous, vous avez rappelé que
davantage d'enfants sont
scolarisés dans les écoles
publiques.
Le taux de chômage des personnes
en situation de handicap est en
baisse de 6 points et
l'accessibilité a été améliorée.
Malgré tout, le chemin est encore
long pour faciliter les parcours,
atteindre l'accessibilité
universelle et favoriser
l'autonomie.
Nous devons construire la
simplification des démarches
administratives encore trop
complexes, améliorer les délais de
traitement des dossiers et trouver
des solutions adaptées aux besoins
réels.
"Que notre politique en matière de
handicap soit sur le chemin de
l'effectivité des droits
fondamentaux universels, de
l'école à l'emploi, de la maison à
la cité", ce sont les mots
d'Emmanuel Macron.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Geneviève Darrieusecq: Merci,
madame la députée Christine Le
Nabour.
Votre question met en lumière la
conférence nationale du handicap
qui s'est tenue mercredi dernier.
C'est un rendez-vous important qui
permet de tracer la route pour les
années à venir en matière de
handicap, qui permet d'avoir des
objectifs forts.
Le plein accès aux droits des
personnes en situation de handicap
et leur inclusion dans notre
société est un peu notre objectif.
Nous voulons aussi mettre en place
les moyens d'arriver à ces
objectifs.
Vous avez décrit la
co-construction avec les 500
personnes qui ont travaillé.
Il y a 70 nouvelles mesures que
nous avons mises en oeuvre et que
nous allons mettre en oeuvre dans
les années à venir.
L'accessibilité, c'est le premier
sujet.
Nous sommes très en retard dans
notre pays.
La Première ministre et le
président de la République, ainsi
que tous les ministres, se sont
accordés à 1,5 milliard qui ont
été mis sur la table pour
améliorer l'accessibilité et
donner un coup de fouet à la mise
en accessibilité, ainsi que les
petits ERP que nous allons mettre
en place pour les personnes
handicapées.
Deuxième chose, le service public
du repérage précoce et de la prise
en charge précoce.
Il faut repérer le plus tôt possible
les handicaps afin de ne pas créer
de sur-handicap.
Il faut une meilleure intégration
dans l'école avec des moyens
médico-sociaux dans les
établissements scolaires, une
meilleure intégration à
l'université, ainsi qu'à la
formation professionnelle et dans
l'emploi.
Je dois dire aussi qu'il faut
l'ouverture des droits des
travailleurs handicapés en
ESAT.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Jean-Félix Acquaviva.
- Jean-Félix Acquaviva: Avec une
croissance exponentielle du prix
du terrain à bâtir deux fois plus
rapide que dans les autres zones
françaises, avec une différence de
pouvoir d'achat en défaveur des
résidents insulaires, les Corses
vivent cela comme une
dépossession.
Ce n'est plus tolérable.
Les tensions se ravivent.
Nous associons à cette question
les territoires qui vivent sous
les mêmes tendances, comme le Pays
basque, la Côte d'Azur, les
Vosges, ou encore le littoral
atlantique.
Les travaux parlementaires
préconisent certaines mesures
intéressantes, mais insuffisantes.
Si nous ne donnons pas aux
collectivités la possibilité
d'agir de manière énergique, la
montagne accouchera d'une souris
et les déceptions seront grandes.
Des propositions ont été faites en
ce sens.
Certaines ont été adoptées par des
assemblées territoriales
délibérantes et par cette
Assemblée nationale à plusieurs
reprises.
Il y a trois types de mesures.
Tout d'abord, l'exercice en droit
de présentation dans certaines
zones pour avoir un équilibre
disparu aujourd'hui.
Ensuite, la taxation des
transactions immobilières pour les
résidences secondaires à partir
d'un certain seuil.
Ensuite, la possibilité d'accéder
à des biens en fonction des zones.
Etes-vous prête à créer un accord
politique transpartisan autour de
ce type de mesures
proportionnées?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Klein, ministre chargé
de la Ville et du Logement.
- Olivier Klein: Merci.
Monsieur le député, vous nous
interpellez à juste titre sur
l'enjeu du logement en Corse,
celle de la spéculation
immobilière et foncière et des
difficultés de plus en plus
grandes que rencontrent les
ménages corses pour se loger, et
ceux qui y habitent à l'année.
Ces difficultés sont bien réelles.
Elles sont aussi partagées par les
territoires basques ou bretons,
notamment.
Face à ce constat, nous agissons
avec la majorité.
Le nombre de communes pouvant
majorer la taxe d'habitation sur
les résidences secondaires va être
étendue dans quelques semaines et
les maires vont pouvoir décider
d'appliquer ou non cette
majoration.
Cette extension du zonage va
également permettre à davantage de
communes d'appliquer les
réglementations existantes sur les
meublés touristiques à travers la
numérotation d'enregistrement et
le changement d'usage.
Vous faites aussi partie du groupe
de travail que nous avons lancé
avec Olivia Grégoire et Dominique
Faure afin d'évacuer ce problème
majeur de l'attrition du logement.
Il y a aujourd'hui 73 propositions
et contributions qui sont sur
l'établi.
Elles seront tout étudiées.
Nous vous donnerons des réponses
avant l'été.
Bien évidemment, il y a aussi le
comité stratégique entre le
gouvernement et la Corse qui
travaillent à cette question
spécifique.
Il y a le chantier que nous a
donné madame la Première ministre
et le président de la République,
les questions de décentralisation
du logement sur lesquels nous
sommes à l'oeuvre.
Je souligne la proposition de loi
déposée par le groupe Renaissance
qui vise à lutter contre
l'éviction des résidences
permanentes en zone tendue.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Jean-Félix Acquaviva: Je
souhaite que, vu l'urgence, un
accord politique global soit fait
et qu'on ne réponde pas à côté.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Thomas Portes pour La France
Insoumise.
- Thomas Portes: Chaque année,
48.000 personnes décèdent à cause
de la pollution en France.
Le secteur des transports génère
30% des émissions.
Notre pays dispose d'un outil
formidable: le fret ferroviaire
public.
Un outil menacé.
Nous avons appris que le 18
janvier 2023, la Commission
européenne a lancé une commission
d'enquête pour déterminer si
l'entreprise "a bénéficié d'aides
publiques allant à l'encontre de
la concurrence libre".
Une enquête encouragée par la SNCF
que les cheminots ont massivement
combattue.
Au moment où la loi européenne sur
le climat fait obligation légale
de réduire les émissions de
l'Union Européenne d'ici à 2030,
Bruxelles a lancé une nouvelle
offensive libérale pour liquider
le fret ferroviaire en France.
Sans outil public et sans monopole
d'Etat, il n'y aura pas de
transition écologique possible.
Après 15 ans de libéralisation, le
bilan est sur une belle pente
depuis 2006, date de l'ouverture à
la concurrence.
Des millions de camions ont été
transférés sur nos routes.
15.000 cheminots étaient alors
salariés, contre 5000 aujourd'hui.
La SNCF a fait le choix de ne pas
contester l'ouverture de l'enquête
et prépare le terrain pour
faciliter la liquidation du fret
SNCF.
Vous avez rencontré la Commission
européenne.
Allez-vous vous opposer à la
possibilité d'une discontinuité de
l'activité qui signerait la mort
du fret SNCF et serait un nouveau
scandale écologique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur Thomas Portes.
Le fret ferroviaire est une
priorité et il ne faut pas dire
des mensonges à son égard.
Vous avez, par un tweet, dit un
mensonge de plus, en disant que le
fret ferroviaire était détruit par
le gouvernement qui visait à le
supprimer.
C'est faux.
Le train reprend son activité en
ce moment même, après avoir été
perturbé par les mouvements
sociaux.
L'ouverture de la procédure n'a
pas à être approuvée ou à être
contestée.
J'ai eu plusieurs réunions avec la
vice-présidente de la Commission
européenne afin de préserver le
fret ferroviaire en France,
préserver un opérateur de fret
ferroviaire, et défendre le fret
SNCF qui n'a rien à voir avec les
soucis que vous évoquez.
La procédure ouverte par la porte
sur d'autres sujets et une autre
période.
Revenons aux faits.
Ce sera plus sain pour le débat.
Nous avons mis en place un plan
inédit en 2021, 1 milliard d'euros
en soutien au fret ferroviaire.
Ce plan se déploie si bien que les
chiffres que vous donnez sont
désormais invalidés, puisqu'il y a
une augmentation pour la première
fois depuis d'une décennie de la
part du fret ferroviaire en
France.
Nous allons investir encore dans
les infrastructures de fret
ferroviaire.
J'espère que vous voterez les
crédits qui y sont destinés dans
le prochain budget.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Portes?
- Thomas Portes: Votre politique
est responsable des gens qui
décèdent de votre inaction
politique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean Terlier.
- Jean Terlier: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre des
Transports, alors que le
département du Tarn porte encore
les stigmates de manifestations à
Sivens, le risque d'une nouvelle
ZAD inquiète.
Il y a une manifestation contre
l'autoroute A69.
Je remercie les forces de l'ordre
et les services de l'Etat qui ont
permis d'éviter tout débordement.
Le sud du Tarn est un territoire
enclavé qui souffre d'un déficit
d'attractivité.
Depuis 30 ans, l'ensemble des élus
locaux, le département du Tarn et
la région se battent pour obtenir
l'arrivée de l'A69.
C'est cette majorité qui a
sanctuarisé le financement de ce
projet.
C'est Jean Castex qui a annoncé le
choix du concessionnaire à côté de
Castres, en raison des
surcompensations
environnementales.
La commission a rendu un avis
positif.
Les travaux préparatoires ont
débuté.
Le renoncement de l'Etat serait
une tragédie pour ce bassin
d'emploi de plus de 100.000
personnes et pour les habitants du
sud du Tarn, favorables à plus de
75% à la construction de cette
autoroute.
Cette question nous semble avoir
été purgée dans le cadre de
l'autoroute A69 et l'Etat de droit
commande que le contrat de
concession autoroutier et les
autorisations administratives ne
soient pas remises en cause.
Pouvez-vous venir lever les
inquiétudes des habitants du sud
du Tarn et sur cette autoroute, et
préciser les conditions de ce
projet?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Madame la
présidente, monsieur Jean Terlier.
Merci de votre engagement et des
précisions que vous avez
rappelées.
Merci d'avoir attendu des élus
locaux des réponses.
Ils ont dit leur soutien en ce
projet qui est discuté depuis
longtemps et qui a fait l'objet
d'engagements importants ces
derniers mois et ces dernières
années.
Vous avez rappelé le contenu et le
calendrier.
La revue que j'évoque ne doit pas
susciter de fantasmes.
Il y a une revue des projets
autoroutiers qui portera sur un
certain nombre de règles qui ne
sont pas engagées et qui peuvent
poser des questions sur l'impact
et sur le coût des péages
associés.
Il y aura des décisions qui seront
prises d'ici l'été et qui vont
clarifier ce point.
Pour les projets engagés, c'est
différent.
Cela ne veut pas dire qu'on ne va
pas chercher des améliorations.
Vous avez parlé du plan
environnemental.
Je recevrai dans les
prochains jours la société
concessionnaire s'il y a des
améliorations nécessaires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Christine
Loir.
- Christine Loir: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Santé.
Depuis le lundi 6 février et la
création du collectif Les
infirmiers libéraux en colère, le
gouvernement reçoit chaque jour
des courriers d'infirmiers
libéraux qui n'en peuvent plus,
afin de vous alerter sur leurs
conditions de travail.
Ces courriers sont restés
jusqu'ici lettre morte.
Les infirmiers et les infirmières
libérales, car ce sont
majoritairement des femmes, sont
pourtant un des maillons
essentiels de notre société pour
assurer la continuité des soins.
Leur importance est connue de
tous.
Leurs revendications sont
légitimes.
Encore une fois, elles ne sont pas
écoutées.
Obtenir une revalorisation des
honoraires et des indemnités
devient urgent.
Après 10 années passées sans que
le tarif des actes médicaux n'ait
été réévalué, vous avez réévalué
le prix de la consultation des
médecins de 1,5 euros.
Quid des infirmières?
Ajoutez à cela les indemnités de
déplacement qui sont de 2,5 euros
par trajet, quelle que soit la
distance.
Quand on connaît l'augmentation du
prix du carburant, c'est un
scandale.
Allez-vous attendre que tous nos
professionnels de santé soient
dans la rue?
Nos infirmières libérales
attendent des réponses et des
actions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Merci.
Je ne peux pas vous laisser dire
que le gouvernement ne prend en
considération les demandes des
infirmiers.
Au contraire.
C'est une réforme globale qui est
conduite sous l'autorité de la
Première ministre.
Concernant leur rémunération, la
mise en place du bilan a été un
succès à tel point que nous
doublons les engagements
financiers sur la mise en place de
ce BSI jusqu'à 217 millions
d'euros pour favoriser des prises
en charge qui s'éloignent de ce
que vous évoquez.
Les frais kilométriques peuvent
être modulés en fonction des
difficultés.
C'était le cas pour la montagne et
ça peut être le cas dans chaque
département.
Nous agissons aussi sur leur
formation à la rentrée prochaine.
La formation de trois ans des
infirmiers et infirmières va être
rénovée pour mieux répondre aux
besoins de santé et nous allons
modifier leur décret de
compétences pour ne plus être une
simple liste d'actes, mais agir
sur les missions que nous confions
aux infirmiers.
Nous développons l'exercice
pluriprofessionnelle et nous avons
ici même pu discuter de mettre en
place l'accès sous contrôle, sous
supervision, l'accès aux
infirmiers pour des prises en
charge de soins spécifiques.
C'est une modification profonde et
globale des métiers d'infirmiers
qui est en route.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Christine Loir: J'ai reçu les
infirmières libérales.
Ce n'est pas ce qu'elles m'ont
dit.
Je vous ramènerai leurs
revendications.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Anne Le Hénanff.
- Anne Le Hénanff: Monsieur le
ministre du Logement, la Fondation
Abbé Pierre montre que lors de la
séparation conjugale, la
précarisation des conditions de
logement est plus fréquente pour
les femmes.
Parmi les 420.000 couples qui se
séparent chaque année, il est
malheureusement fréquent que la
femme soit contrainte de quitter
le logement conjugal ou familial,
seule ou avec leurs enfants qui
sont parfois très jeunes.
Pour les femmes, en instance de
divorce, cherchant à se loger dans
le parc social, c'est un parcours
du combattant.
Elles doivent fournir une preuve
de leur volonté de se séparer ou
de divorcer.
La réglementation encadrant les
attributions dans le parc social
indique qu'en cas de divorce,
c'est l'ordonnance de
non-conciliation établie par le
juge aux affaires familiales qui
fait foi.
Ce document est parfois difficile
à obtenir et la demande de
logements ne peut intervenir avant
que la procédure de divorce ait
débuté et que la demandeuse se
soit mis en lien avec un avocat.
Enfin, la clause de solidarité du
bail, lorsque des dettes ont été
contractées durant la vie commune,
est un obstacle conséquent, car
quelle que soit l'origine de ces
impayés, la personne demandeuse
doit s'en acquitter pour obtenir
un nouveau logement social.
Quelles mesures le gouvernement
entend mettre en oeuvre pour aider
et accompagner ces milliers de
femmes à se loger rapidement et
dignement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Votre question pose un moment
grave, celui de la cohabitation
lors du divorce.
Nous sommes mobilisés avec mes
collègues et l'ensemble du
gouvernement pour lutter contre
toutes les formes de
discrimination dans l'accès au
logement, et en particulier pour
les femmes avec des situations de
séparation.
En décembre dernier, nous avions
signé une charte de
non-discrimination dans l'accès au
logement et nous travaillons avec
les autres organismes pour signer
ce type de charte avec des agents
immobiliers en particulier.
Lors d'un changement de logement
pour cause de procédure de
divorce, il faut aujourd'hui un
document de non-conciliation et il
est difficile de changer cette
réglementation pour éviter toute
forme d'abus.
Nous travaillons pourtant avec les
différents ministères à simplifier
les démarches administratives de
nos concitoyens et concitoyennes.
Pour les situations les plus
graves, celles de violences, nous
avons des dispositions
d'hébergement d'urgence sur
lesquels nous sommes attentifs.
Plus de 10.000 places ont été
ouvertes et la Première ministre a
annoncé encore 1000 places
supplémentaires pour cette année
2023.
C'est un gain important, mais il
n'est pas suffisant pour régler
tous les problèmes.
Il faut continuer à produire du
logement.
Une des difficultés est celle du
manque de logements, ce qui
accentue cette difficulté.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
suspendue.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA